- You got there because
you put out great content
that people wanna watch.
- [Male] Ladies and
gentleman, female Viagra.
- It's like--
- Well, lets take
a step back, is that because
you, I mean, obviously
you even looking like
you, what you're doing
with your look attire, is
that 'cause you just love
that stuff and that that would be cool?
Like, is that 'cause
you think that's where
the most money is?
Like, why does that run through your mind?
- It runs through my mind
because I feel like--
- The amount of follower
too we have, it's like--
- Well, to me but you can do a million...
So, let me give you an example.
The reason I did the K-Swiss
deal is because my whole
life is predicated on
buying older, nostalgic
brands and remarketing them.
So, Adidas or Nike would
have been a pass for me
because that wasn't me
resurrecting a brand.
Got it?
So if Nike had come along
or Adidas and offered me
ten times the money
that K-Swiss offered me,
I would have said no
because for me, my goal
is eventually turning my
whole empire into buying
Cracker Jacks or Sprite or Captain Crunch
and buying it for $200
million and selling it
for $2 billion, that's what
I wanna do for a living.
So when I ask you, like,
why do you wanna do it?
When you say, "We have a huge audience.",
cool you can also go on
tour and make $7 million
by JV'ing with somebody to put you on tour
to do that, you know.
To me, if I understand
what, now if you said,
"I love fucking clothes
and it'd be super cool
"and my friends would think..."
Like, that's a great answer.
- Right.
- So to me, do you see where I'm going?
- Yeah.
- To me, I wanna go--
- Why.
- Why?
- Why because if it's...
It's the fucking question.
- Yeah.
- Because once you understand
why, like, if the answer
is 'cause that's what I
perceive to make the most money.
- Yeah.
- Well, then I would say
okay let's take a step back.
Let me tell you how I
think that would play out.
Remind me, like, what you're
doing, how you're doing it.
So I think that's why it's
such an important question.
- Of course, of course.
Everything starts with my
love for video creation.
I can, I love creating, like that's me.
That's what I'm in, fuckin' that's me.
That's what saved me.
I had PTSD, I went overseas, anxiety.
You know, I promised guys
over there, they're like
you're funny as fuck, you're
crazy doin' pranks you know.
I helped them out over
there, I was like moral.
And I was like yeah, I
promise you guys, I'll do it.
You know, and came back
a little fucked up, PTSD,
anxiety, just didn't wanna go out.
Kind of unmotivated.
- Of course.
- And then, I just kind
of like one day, you said
with your fitness, I just
woke up and said fuck this.
This isn't what I wanna
do, I wanna create.
And that's when I started making funny ass
Facebook videos, started postin' 'em up,
started catchin' on, and
as I was doin' the videos
I was slowly helpin' myself.
- Love it.
- Comin' out of you know,
so for me to go to New York
even three years ago it was nothin'.
Couldn't do it.
- I understand.
- And so, the video creation
along with just, you know,
life, it just clicks.
- That's awesome.
- Now I got all these fans.
- Yep.
- I got all these brands
that are after me.
- Yep.
- What the fuck
do I wanna promote other brands for?
- I get it.
- You know what I mean?
- The reason you wanna
promote other brands is
'cause they pay tens of
thousands of dollars.
- Of course.
- Right.
- That would be the
answer to your question.
- Of course, yes.
- But the question becomes
how and what do you
wanna do next, you know,
is just a very big deal.
- Right.
- Of course I know that it is.
- Here's, lemme tell
you a couple of things
that will probably make you feel good.
That will get you guys pumped.
There aren't that many
things you can do wrong.
Let's start there.
- I'll agree with that, yeah.
- You know, like I think
you know, watching people
go through this that
you're going through now,
this like, holy shit.
Listen, I've been doing
this a long, long time.
Like I watched people
live this on MySpace,
so for me this is just the
same show over and over.
- Right.
What you could do wrong
is take it for granted.
- Of course.
- The only thing
that influencers right
now that are popping
are vulnerable to is
taking it for granted.
They amount of kids that
took Vine for granted
and were lazy and now are sad
and wanna be relevant again,
but are super behind in the
Instagram world, you know?
- Right.
- The people that took MySpace
for granted or early Twitter.
Like, I've watched this over and over.
So I think one of the things
that you have in your advantage
is you're probably based
on your age and the limited
I know about your background,
already in a place
where you'll probably appreciate
it more and grind harder
which is a humongous variable.
That's number one.
I think what you need...
Look, I think this notion
of like fuck this, like
I'm not gonna build up fuckin' Supreme.
I'm gonna start Supreme is
rad and like I will never
suppress anything but
it's about self-awareness.
- Of course.
- Like it's not that easy
to start a brand.
- No, of course.
- There's a lot of infrastructure.
Not that I'm against it.
Here's what I would say, I'm
a big fan of starting slow.
So, the first thing you
should give a lot of thought
to is getting somewhat knowledgeable about
e-commerce in general, right.
Like starting a Shopify store
or something of that nature.
- Which we just started.
- Great.
- I don't wanna interrupt.
- No, you're not interrupting.
- 'Cause I was listenin' to you--
- I'm here to like listen and help you.
- Yeah, yeah so basically like,
with the whole Shopify stuff
I, what really hit me from
you is if you suck at it,
you fuckin' suck at it, you know.
- Yeah, and you can hire somebody.
- That's what I'm, that's what--
- Like, to me, to me when
you're makin' these dollars now
like what are you, you
know, I always say this,
what are you doing with it?
So of course--
- I just throw it back in.
- And that's it, of course
you wanna, you're buying
something with it, but
like, be thoughtful of how
you're allocating, to me, it's what I did.
Like these characters didn't use to exist.
It was me on my phone,
like, do you pour it
back into like, is Sally
sitting here in three months
when you come back and
visit or a year later
and she was, you know,
head of e-com for the,
you know, the Dunkin Donuts.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause she lives up there or
you know, that kind of shit.
- Yeah of course.
- Do you know what I mean?
- Yeah, yeah absolutely.
- I think you have to think
about that and I'd also
say I'm not so sold
that product is the right
answer, other than if you
feel passionate about
it and you think it is.
Then that's great, I just
wanna make sure that touring,
more brand deals, speaking,
writing a comedy book.
Like, you know, going
to a production company
and trying to do a Netflix's special.
Like there's still a lot
of things to talk about.
- Right.
- There's a lot I've been
so, my story in general, I
am very influential, I'm very
out spoken and I really
pump people up kind of like.
So, for me it's like how
do I even start just goin'
to get in front of people,
like, I would even like
to go to companies and
be like, listen you know
you guys are wastin' your
money on these ads when--
- So, one of the ways you
can do that is literally
one day instead of creating,
the other way you create
is through biz dev and you know, hustling.
And I would email Dunkin
Donuts and Marshall's
and Boews--
- I've done--
- And all, but I'm just
named three New England
based companies.
- Yeah.
- You know don't have
to go very fuckin' far.
- Yeah.
- Right?
- Reebok up there,
everybody's fuckin', Sam
Adams, like I don't know.
Send 'em an email, be
like, if it's titled like
I think I can bring you value.
I have a million or close,
I don't know what your
numbers are, like, followers on Instagram.
I think your brands are misplaying it.
One out of those 97 people
are gonna be like, come.
- Yeah, always.
- And then the second
you then have the ability
to then say, well I spoke
at Reebok, it becomes
fuckin' like dominoes.
- It's kind of happening in a way now.
- I'm sure it is.
- Doin' the trailer
for Paramount, they're
extremely pleased, they wanna
work more and--
- That's awesome.
- Yeah.
- So it's just like--
- And they gave me 20 hours.
They literally called 'em
and said can this kid do it?
They went through Nine
Gag, and it's you know,
it's what I do, I love
creatin' like products.
- Do you have a sense,
so back to creating.
Your, you know, I think one
of the things that really
worked out for me that I
was always, that I can do
a better job communicating
on which is in hindsight
I was a creator and an entrepreneur.
Like the thing that you
know is playing out for me
as I'm going through a
lot of this stuff is like
you know, a lot of people are like, shit.
You're fuckin' really creative, right?
Like my creative team,
you know, Ryan Harwood,
my partner in the media
publishing side, he's like
I have meetings with you
'cause you're a creator.
You're creative, you know, D Rock
and my team says it,
so do you have a sense,
do you think you're a good entrepreneur?
Do you think you could build a business?
- I think I can build a business.
- Good well then you gotta just try.
- Yeah.
- You gotta prove it
to yourself.
- 100%.
- I mean I think, look,
I think the biggest thing
you need to be careful of is,
I think people over stress
themselves thinking that
they're in this remarkable...
You know, at one point I'm
saying, don't take it for granted
and now I'm about to tell
you, like, don't think
it's that remarkable that
you become over stressed
that you put too much
pressure on yourself.
- Yeah, of course.
- For example, if you continue
to produce content that
people wanna watch,
you'll continue to have leverage.
I think the one thing I
would tell you is do not
become too reliant, so tell me what is
going on with your platforms.
So I know obviously
you're winning on Insta.
- So Facebook, obviously,
we were talkin' to Talia
before just did a crash overnight, I mean,
it took everybody's,
breach just like that 70%.
- Instagram's gonna do the same thing.
- I 100% know that.
- So yeah--
- We know that, we know
that's already known.
- It was just like--
- Where are you on YouTube?
Where are you in your own dotcom?
Where are you on Twitter?
- So YouTube, we have about 500,000.
That's where we put our
longer form content out.
Facebook we actually just
received a watch page
which is basically what
the future of Facebook's
going to be.
- Maybe.
- That, maybe, they're tryin' to at least.
We don't know, they're all over the place.
- Where are you on posting
organic on your fan page?
- On Facebook?
Still normal, if we a
video for Instagram--
- Good.
- I still post it
on Facebook.
- Keep goin'.
- Seein' where it's at--
- How much are you
community managing on Facebook?
- As in--
- You post, people comment,
you jump in and reply to every comment?
- Instagram I do, every message too.
- I message too.
- Love it.
But you're not doin' it on Facebook?
- I do, I answer messages always on both.
- But you're not replying
to the comments on Facebook?
- He does.
- Sometimes, not like--
- I respect it, religious on Instagram--
- Yeah.
- As much as you can
on the others.
- Yeah of course.
- Okay.
- Instagram--
- What about Twitter?
- I don't even use it really.
- You need to go on it.
- I know, I already--
- I mean Barstool is
like living off of it.
- Yeah, that's one of the
things I need to do right away.
- So it's a huge--
- Like totally--
- It's always been.
- Literally you should go
into your hotel room
tonight and like start up
your like, create it and
make your first video.
Be like, Gary V yelled at
me, here's my first one.
And then you need to go
to Instagram in your story
and be like I fucked
up, I went to New York,
Gary V yelled at me, go
follow me on my Twitter.
- Yeah.
- Tomorrow.
- Okay.
- Because first of all you
can put some, you can put
what is it 140, 280, what is it?
- [Camera Man] It's more
than one (inaudible)
- It's more than 140, I think
it's 280 but seems weird.
But like you put close to three minutes,
I think maybe more videos.
You're making one minute
videos on Instagram.
- Yep.
- Here's my thing.
You can't create friction
for your audience.
- [Camera Man] 220.
- 220, you can't create friction.
What if somebody loves Twitter.
- Right.
- Yes.
- Well they're not on Twitter so whatever
I'm not gonna follow 'em.
- That's true.
- Yeah.
- Twitter's also a place
where there's a unique,
different thing, there's like...
Here's my thing, this is
it, like, this could be
the rest of your life, like
you can really win this game.
- Right.
- This is it.
I mean, there's--
- Well, I get it.
You want it to be.
- Yeah.
- But I know that the economy's
gonna collapse eventually.
I know that there's gonna
be a million people, like,
supply and demand of
people that want your life
right now, is every
single person 13 to 22.
- Of course.
- Every single, but before
we get into of course, I wanna
make you leave with this.
Right now, in America and
that's not even counting
global but let's just stick with it.
If you are 12 to 22, your goal in life is
to be an influencer on social networks.
That is your number one ambition.
That means what you have
behind you is ten million
funny people who are
gonna start off at zero
when you're not gonna be at zero anymore.
It's just like boxing.
Somebody's gonna be
more desperate than you.
So, I think that when
you're in this moment,
it's just inexcusable to
not make content everywhere
you can out of what's hot now.
You've already in your
short period of time,
lived winning on Facebook
and then losing organic drop.
Like, you're basically like
you need to be religious
on none of these fuckin'
platforms are gonna have
the leverage on me, I'm
gonna create all of them.
Do you know, I could give a fuck
which platform goes or not?
I'm winning on all of 'em.
Got it?
- Yeah, fuck yeah.
- You don't wanna wake up
tomorrow with a headline,
when you post something
you're like, why didn't we
just get a fifth of the views
or likes that we're used to?
It's already happening on Instagram.
- Of course, yeah I've seen it.
- You know, anybody who's
creating everyday knows
it's already starting to happen.
- So what would you
recommend for us as far as--
- Everything.
- Okay (giggling).
- Yeah 'cause, it's good that--
- I think, I think you
should start a podcast.
I think you should write
fuckin' stuff on LinkedIn.
I think you should fuckin',
you need to squeeze
the fuck out of this moment.
What, you wanna go get a job?
- Nah, fuck that.
- No he can't go back
to a job, but he's doing this full-time.
- But you understand?
- Yeah.
- And like, at the, you
know this Paramount thing,
I mean I think you probably
know this and I respect
the fuck outta three
jobs, so I just excited me
so good shit.
- Yeah.
- But like, very quickly
you could be back to none,
you could be at none, I mean,
this could go real fast.
- Right and that's--
- Yeah, of course.
- That's scary, we definitely
don't want that to happen.
That's why we're being
as proactive as possible.
- Yeah.
- Well, so to me it's like
it's like you're getting
seduced by the platform
that you're growing on.
- Of course.
- And then you get caught.
- Yeah, and selective.
- I do, yeah of course.
- Like you should have an
email list that you send
an exclusive video to just
there 'cause guess what,
you own that for life.
- Yeah.
- Diversification, right, diversification.
- Yeah, 100%.
- Yeah and it's worth it,
right, so what may happen is
you're like, wait a minute.
I'm actually replying to every, half, look
you only have 24 hours,
like even if you...
There's only so much you
can, you know, like it's
smart to sleep, it's like you got your 18,
17 you know 19 hours right?
So like you gotta maximize those.
I think diversifying your
platforms is extremely important.
- I agree.
- It's been the cliche
biggest mistake of influencers
over the last decade.
They get high on the thing
that is winning for them
at the moment and then they
don't wanna put in the work
in other places, like, to
me you've lived it already.
Like, why would you not be on Twitter?
- I know, it's...
- Like if you were like
let's play it out.
- 'Cause I think it's
we don't use Twitter, so we're like oh--
- It's like you said, I just
got obsessed with Instagram.
- It's not about you.
- I know.
- I never think about what I do.
If somebody's consuming shit on Twitter--
- Right.
- It's true, I've seen
my videos goin' viral
on Twitter, still on.
Yeah, fuck.
- That's why you schleped
down here.
- Yeah, yeah.
(laughing)
I mean--
- You didn't come here
for my good looks, you came
here to get some fuckin' shit.
This is shit, it's shit that matters.
- I survived YouTube too, I mean, that I'm
not doin' Apocalypse when
80% of all my friends
got dropped over night.
- Of course.
- And--
- There'll be ups
and downs, it's, these are networks.
NBC's rolling when Seinfeld's
on, when it's not, it's not.
Today Facebook's this,
tomorrow, Facebook does Y,
Twitter does X, Twitter
was cold, then politics
got it hot, like Snapchat, dead.
Sure until tomorrow
when Snapchat announces
some crazy shit like fuckin'
Princess Lei hologram shit.
And everyone's like oh
fuck, I should have been
paying attention to Snapchat.
Got it?
- Yeah.
- Or it becomes fuckin' Friendster.
I don't know, I'm just not
gonna fuckin' allow myself
to be vulnerable.
- So you're just in fuckin'
everything, now, can
I ask you if something
does die do you just continue?
- No, I mean I'm not
posting on Tumblr anymore.
I made my fuckin' dirt on
Tumblr back in the day.
Viddler was my YouTube, so absolutely not.
But while there's still
stuff going on I do not,
look, you don't revive
something that's dead
but sometimes something that's
sick rises like a phoenix.
- Yeah of course.
- Got it?
- Of course.
- Dead is dead.
But Snapchat's not dead.
- I still post everyday
on Snap--
- Right.
- So I still do the Snap,
Instagram, Facebook, YouTube.
- Good, so you gotta add Twitter.
I think, LinkedIn's tricky for what you do
though I think you could
write the occasional
like, how humor, like this
may not even be up your alley.
So I'm not obsessed with LinkedIn for you
but I would say why
corporations need to take, like
what I really wanna talk
to corporations about,
that would be a good LinkedIn post.
Or you could write something
like, your three minute
escape from your desk at
your job, 'cause remember
the thought, you gotta
always reverse engineer
the psychology of the user.
So maybe you do a whole series
of like, 60 second laughs
while you're at work.
Like you name 'em that,
you see where I'm going?
- Yeah, of course.
- Or like, not safe at work
you know, from your buddy
again, you see where I'm going?
- Of course, yes.
- You gotta kind of give
a wink to the audience.
- Yeah, and you kind of got
a look, you know 'cause, of
course Facebook is different
than Instagram fans and you
can clearly see everyday.
- 100%.
- So you know, you would
always wanna generate--
- My content on LinkedIn
like, the push back on cursing is extreme
'cause it's a professional place.
- Yeah.
- So like cool, I've gotta
make a decision of like, I said it to you.
I'm like look, we need to
start considering to censor
on LinkedIn because the
audience is always right.
I can't be like, fuck you.
- Yeah.
- I gotta be like, I respect you.
The audience is how
you're making your money.
Paramount didn't give you
money 'cause of your looks.
Paramount gave you money
'cause you have eyeballs.
- Of course.
- They're your currency.
- No, I know.
- Like you just wanna stop with him
doin' three fuckin' jobs.
- I see people and you have (laughing).
- No honestly, by the way, I think--
- No I do.
- Well then great that's
honest enough, but yeah
that would be a reasonable
answer, like one of the
reason's I'd be like, fuck it
let's do it full time
is like, it's more fun
to do this than get paid--
- It is.
- But if you love what
you do, then I'm like
you know, then I would be patient.
- Right.
- Yes.
- Like how do you get it?
Like, you're only, you
know how many people
would rip their arms off,
like now, you've been
doing it on Facebook for awhile right?
- Right.
- Yes well Facebook actually
did the same shit when YouTube died--
- I get it.
- I had a mil on Facebook
in six months, I went
ballistic (inaudible)
- Look I think you clearly
have a content comedic style
that resonates with people.
- Yeah.
- I would tell you that never goes away.
So you know, to me it's
just about being thoughtful.
The more fuckin' detox
tea and dumb shit you do,
the more likely you won't win.
So like the longer you
can wait, I mean, look
you guys are young as fuck, it's like,
you're gonna struggle
from me giving you any
other answer of like,
they will come if you
keep building your fucking audience.
- Right.
- Of course.
- That's how they came in the first place.
- I agree.
- Like, where do you
think they came from, when
you had 3,000 followers
on Instagram they weren't coming.
- Yeah (laughing).
- Like, they showed
up when you started to
have hundreds of thousands,
like it's not super complicated.
- Right.
- Yeah.
- And like, when you have four million,
more of 'em will come and
the numbers will be bigger.
- Right, it's just for
me like, I see all these
people that, you know, they
love us and they follow us--
- The worst start to a sentence ever.
- Okay.
- Like, literally the worst
start to a sentence ever is
but for me I see other people.
- No, I see our fans like I see the people
that are following us,
our fan base like the--
- Okay.
- The 1 mil on Instagram
and I'm like we have, you
know, a million people
following us, if we sold
a bracelet that says
HammyTV for one dollar
to one million people.
- You wouldn't though,
that's not how many people,
that's not how it would work.
- I just am trying to think how we can.
- I said maybe--
- That's not the way
it's gonna be.
- Okay.
- Yeah that's...
- First of all, why don't
you have a million one
views on every video then?
- We do.
- So you're getting
more views than your audience size?
- Yeah, always.
- And the audience--
- Let's look.
- Okay.
- How any videos are you posting a day?
- We just post three
times a week right now.
- That's it?
- Yeah.
- Why?
- Because I can
only prank so much.
- Well, right.
I get it.
- Prank, comedy.
We're gettin' into skits
now so that's definitely,
we're hyping it up.
I think I only have--
- Have you thought about,
it makes sense now why
your views are, they're
sitting in your stream, makes sense.
But I mean, these are bonkers numbers.
- Yeah, since then--
- Like..
- Like yesterday's video
has four million, no 2X, I mean
all the analytics are there.
It's all real, I just know
I just can create viral--
- You just know what
the audience, like you,
you're reverse engineering
what you know is gonna work.
- So I also, so I gotta, do
you know of man Steve Bartlett?
- Steve Bartlett, yeah.
- Steve Bartlett and my
business partner's Jeff
Taylor, I don't know.
We both have 22 pages
together as well on Facebook
and this is one way we found how we went
about going extremely viral.
I post a video and we share
across the whole entire network.
- Yep, a lot of people do that.
- Yeah, of course so
that's another thing that I
started doing too as well
so on those 22 pages as well
but when the reach dropped,
it's kind of changed everything.
- Always.
- But, like you said
we're jus tryin' to kinda
see what Facebook's doin'
but I still am postin'
the content on Facebook.
I'm still doin' the
Facebook stories, along
with everything else.
And luckily, we just got a
Watch Page, which is cool
'cause its reach is
bonkers on that as well.
I'm sure you're seeing it's
like, 70% or something' insane
'cause they're pushin' that now.
So, I worked my ass off
to get that and so we're
gonna be startin' on that again tomorrow.
It was just built and
I'm, I've got my dotcom
being built and I've been dabbling
in the e-commerce as well,
which I'm just gettin'
settin' up the shop, doin' like you said.
So I mean, right after I read your book
I just went fuckin' crazy.
I mean literally, I'm
telling you I'm not fuckin'
kiddin' you, like I didn't
know, I didn't give a fuck.
A million, I don't care about a million.
It doesn't excite me,
a million views doesn't
excite me either, none
of that shit excites me.
And the money, of course,
is great but I don't
just focus on the money, I just--
- The money would be
there if you care about
the audience and produce good shit.
You'll win.
- My audience is just,
which is one reason I'm
scared, like you said,
I'm not gonna take this cheap ass brand--
- So don't.
- And be like,
which I have not, you know,
in the long run I'm doin'
what you said with the patience.
I'm not gonna hold up fuckin' detox teas
for a $500 shout out.
That's just shit I don't use.
I think of the fans, what would they like?
If it fits my brand and
I've turned down many
that do not fit, not just
because of the money,
but they just don't fit.
- I get it.
- You know, my audience to me is family.
That's my fuckin'--
- It's also the only
ass that you have.
- Right.
- Yeah, yeah it is.
- It's the only thing you got.
- And like you said, I
look for the longevity.
I'm not gonna sit there
and sell 'em some bullshit.
I'm lookin' for the long, you know, when I
possibly come up with brand
or whatever I decide to do
and these people are fuckin'
die hard 'cause I take
two seconds just to message
'em back and they're
like, that's my mother
fuckin' dude, you know?
- 100,000%.
- And that's what--
- The Ricky Henderson rule.
- Yeah, I'm just--
- I believe in it tremendously.
- I see what you mean as well, like I just
go ballistic and it's
just a connection now.
It's like they know you and they met you--
- Of course.
- Just from a simple hi,
thank you, you know, and I said--
- It's the best, of course.
- And we are startin' to
get into skits, which I
can pop a skit in everyday.
- Yeah, one of the things
I would tell you is
I do think there's, I do
think there's a debate
for you to do like still images.
Like, I think you should
play a little bit.
I would tell you, you getting
180,000 views on a video
off of the things I'm seein'
between one and four million
and I'm sayin' this for
a reason, is probably
really the best thing
that can happen to you.
I think one of the things
that's holding you back now
is the success of every piece of content
and I think it becomes
crippling instead of a positive.
- I do too, which is why
this skit made me feel
so fuckin' free, when I made the skit
'cause it wasn't just a prank.
It felt free, I was tellin' her--
- I mean, even just an occasional video
of you straight to your
face and just saying,
yo, thank you.
Just mixing it up, I mean,
I'll be honest with you,
I just had a great day too
'cause I fuckin' did...
I don't mix it up really either, like,
I did a, just a post of
like looking in the...
I never do this and the
thing was I Easter egged
a random person and just
tagged them and they've
gotten fuckin'--
- Oh wow.
- They've gotten like
1,400 followers in the last
couple of hours.
- That's amazing.
- Yeah.
- And like, like just
mixing it up.
- Yeah, just tryin--
- It matters.
- New shit, yeah
so the skit is somethin'
that I recently just did.
And it's at a million and people loved it
and I really love the skits as well.
Pranks are fun but they get boring.
I'm just funny as fuck, it's how I am.
So the skit--
- I get it.
- Is somethin' that I
wanna get into as well.
I mean, it's perfect, we love it.
We enjoy it, my shit's edgy but you know,
I try to keep it down a little
bit because of the brands
but I'm just, you know--
- I mean, look.
The edgy stuff is what
it is, like, you know,
yeah, I remember lettin' the kid.
There's brands that are
not gonna fuck with you
and then there's other
brands that are gonna
come at you hard.
- Yeah.
- You know, if American
Pie the movie was making
a reboot, like, you'd get
all that Paramount money.
- Johnny Knoxville, that's
what that was just for.
- You know what I mean?
- So, but I love what you said too
because diversifying does, it's just--
- It's also your sense of humor.
- Yeah.
- Yeah like he's--
- That's just me.
- Some people are gonna
be like Andrew Dice Clay
is Andrew Dice Clay,
like fuckin', Richard
Pryor is Richard Pryor.
Like, you know, like dude I fuckin' live
in corporate America
and curse my face off.
There's real business here.
- Of course, I agree.
- Like, but I also gain
business 'cause of it.
Like, it's gonna be
what it's gonna be like
altering your truth is always a bad idea.
- Like, I'm with you, I
respect it because I love it.
I love that when you
hear the fuck's, that's
just how I grew up. (all laughing)
You know, like it pumps me up, you know.
I mean, I went overseas
and shit and that's how
I talk, you know.
- Of course.
- I don't wanna change,
like you know, she's,
I was like it's Gary V,
she's gotta dress sexy.
Like, it's just not me, I
just, this is what I wear.
You know, I just like, I'm my own boss
because I just like to be what, you know,
what I like to do.
- That's the best part
right, you just like get to be yourself.
- Well, she just likes dressin' sexy.
- Well we're goin' out for drinks--
- Well, if I looked like
her I'd look sexy too.
- Yeah, I know.
- You roll with what you have.
(laughing)
Life's very basic.
- I never get to dress up.
- You need to do your
thing like, enjoy it.
You're a workin' man, you
get to do it your way.
Listen, I think that a
couple of things stand out.
I think a couple of things
you need to think about.
One, it's early and like
again, in this whole like
you know kind of like, I'm thinkin' this,
you're doin' this, this is awesome.
That's exactly what should be happening.
It's not about, neither
one of you are right.
These, make sure when you're debating
these things, there is no right.
I think that's why we work well toget--
Like, it's not about
right, it's about thoughts.
I will say that selling
stuff's a good idea.
But, I don't think, to your point.
I don't think a Hammy, I
don't think the bracelets
at a dollar, I don't think the T-shirts.
What I would do if I
were you, if you wanted
to go T-shirt, which I
always think is a fun,
light way to start.
- Of course.
- I would look at the content that worked
and make something that's an inside joke
just to your fans.
- Okay.
- So we were thinking of doing a T-shirt
that says like, what was it?
Viagra makes you twerk, or something?
- Yeah.
- 'Cause there was a video
he gave me female Viagra
and I was like twerking
against a wall.
- It went like crazy.
- It went huge and everybody
loved it so it was like,
oh that would be a funny T-shirt.
- That would be great, and that's it.
No even Hammy, not even like, I even hate
when they put my signature,
I'm always debating
like I have my signature,
it's very subtle.
But even that, I'm like.
I think you have such your own vernacular
and your own meme, like
Viagra makes your twerk
based on a video that
went real well for you,
is way better than something
anybody else could say.
A lot of people could
say fake or no filter.
Anybody can say that.
- True, true.
- Right.
- It's not personable.
- You'd rather, so what
people make the mistake
when, so the mistake
you're making right now
is you're thinking width not depth.
I would argue if you put
up based on what I've heard
that Viagra makes you
twerk versus something
more generic that's more
accessible to most people
like, you know no filter
or something like that,
you would sell more of
the first and the audience
would be happier you did it.
- Yeah.
- You know, (inaudible) for female Viagra.
I still haven't gotten back to messages.
- They're like where
that female Viagra is.
- I'm telling you, every
single day, where can I get it?
Where can I get it, where can I get it?
Non-stop.
- That's cool.
- Yeah, it's absurd and
a lot of times I use
products in my video and
they contact right away.
- Of course.
- They're ready to work.
Like those read edibles that I gave her--
- Of course.
- Her sister's on a diet
and I switched her cookies
with edible cookies.
Yeah, just like kind of the egg thing.
- Well, you're goading them in.
- Yeah of course.
- You know that if you use
a product, you'll hear
from them in 24 hours.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, we do it all the time.
- Of course.
- Here's my face mask.
- Yeah, of course, of course.
Look, remember how you got there.
- Yeah.
- You got there
because of views, like--
- Gotta stay humble.
- It's not about that,
it's about you got there
because you put out great
content that people wanna watch.
I think when you make
the transition to trying
to make this a viable
business, as you should,
as they want you to.
Your audience wants a video every day.
And if you can afford to
do that, they're thrilled.
They're not worried
about you making money.
They'll be fine, just like.
Look, I don't have the
cliche things that all
the entrepreneurs have but I'll have like
a sneaker come out.
And like, to me, my
big thing is that like,
I'm thrilled to ask but I don't expect.
And I think that the level
of respect that I have
for my audience is no
question the reason I'm gonna
sit at the top of the tree
because I am different.
I don't disrespect them,
I don't think I'm smarter,
I don't like, wanna just do a quick flip.
And all that shit is gonna play out.
- I agree, and my favorite
thing as just comin'
to New York recently, is
like, our fans are tellin' us
everything, like, this
is the best place to eat,
this is--
- Oh yeah, you made a video
on like, we're driving,
we're on our way, right?
- Yeah.
- I saw somethin'.
- I said Gary V we're on our way.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And like, people have
non-stop, you've gotta come
here, you gotta go here.
- You guys are doin' a meet and greet?
- Yeah.
- That's gonna be great,
that's the best right?
- Central Park meet and
greet and we get to have
like a 100 people or something are coming.
- It's just--
- Just for the fans,
'cause we do love our fans.
- Look, I think you're
on the right path,
here's what I'd say, more
and like, the longer you
can hold your breath.
Of course you're gonna start day dreaming
and getting excited
about what this could be.
Just the longer you can hold out,
the longer you can hold out.
- I haven't even looked
up, you're in the clouds
in the dirt, I'm still
just in the fuckin' dirt.
- I get it, I get it.
- And I'll just keep goin'.
It's just, I love it so much.
- The clouds part
for definition purposes is the why.
Got it.
- Yeah.
- Why and like, you clearly love to create
and you would do this
for free if you could.
- Yeah oh yeah, 100%.
- I get it, I get it.
I get the same high, I get it.
- Yeah, when it goes viral
too I'll get a fuckin' high.
- Yeah, when somethin'
you like thought up.
- Yeah (laughing).
- What's a better
feeling than that?
That's what's fun being a creator right?
- There's nothing better.
- It's in your brain
and then you thought
it would go and it did.
- It's it's, the fact you can create it
and that many people saw it,
like, the Viagra twerk one,
310 million people.
- That's absurd.
- It's a fuckin' sin.
- It's absurd.
- Look at the Super Bowl numbers compared
to a video that I created.
- That's true.
- So and a little trouble we're havin' now
which we're discussin' with Nine Gag is
it's havin' these companies
understand the power
that we actually have.
- Just wait.
- Yeah, I was tellin' Nine
Gag, I was like we're in 2020
because when they realize what you can do,
you know, yeah.
- It's a matter of time.
You gotta hold your breath
as long as possible.
- I agree, 100%.
- It's as simple as that.
- I agree.
- Like, get yours
along the way fine, nice trip to New York.
It's nice to buy a nice jump suit.
That's fine but just don't like, just
create a scenario where
you can hold your breath
the longest, you will
win because the longer
you can continue to just purely
bring the audience value,
you're putting things in the bank.
The second, regardless,
I hate when I have a new
book or a sneaker out, it means I'm taking
out of the bank.
You ask, you can say
whatever you want about
authenticity and this and out, you've...
There's asking and there's giving.
My preference is giving.
- Me too, always.
- But, I wanna, I have my own ambitions
and things of that nature.
I mean, it's Jab, Jab, Jab, Right Hook.
Like, I always think that
Thank You Economy is the
best book I wrote but I love
Jab, Jab, Jab, Right Hook
because it absolutely
articulates how I think about it.
Give, give, give, and then ask.
It's okay to ask but
fuck like, they wouldn't
let me do this but I wanted to call it
Jab, Jab, Jab, Jab, Jab,
there was like nine Jabs.
(all laughing)
And then there was five
and then I was like,
fuck it three, but
nonetheless, like the more
you can be in the jab...
Like, it is fighting,
like you know, it's super
hard to land right hooks if
you keep throwing right hooks
and that's the mistake people make.
'Cause then once they
get on that drug of like
making money, they're like, oh my God.
But now you're starting the decline.
- Yeah, yeah I agree.
- There's only two movements, up and down.
Every time you ask, you're goin' down.
It'll come, it will come.
You already got a big
audience, you clearly
have a skill set, it's worked everywhere.
Overseas for a bunch of guys, on Facebook,
then YouTube, it works.
Get it as many places
as possible and get your
content distributed as
many places as possible.
Meaning, when all these
meme pages and other people
wanna use your content,
the answer's always yes.
- I've been doin' that on IG,
that's how I grew sow quick.
- Of course, because they
can't steal your face.
- Yeah.
- You're not making
your money on ads and commercials.
Do you understand?
- Yeah, of course.
- You want everybody to take your content.
- Yeah, IG all the time,
just tag me, just tag me,
just tag me, tag me, that's it.
The world's--
- Attention is the equity.
It's the asset.
- Yeah it's, just even
the story views, you
know, it's like gettin'
350,000 story views--
- That's incredible.
Yeah, I mean dude your
numbers are staggering.
- Yeah.
- I don't know what
else to tell you, you're
getting way more, like
I've a bigger following
count but I don't have
a bigger audience.
- Yeah.
- Not on IG and those
are like crazy numbers.
- We started pumpin' out more content,
we keep goin', they just don't get bored.
They just, I keep tellin' her--
- Dude--
- We just gave 'em one today.
Now they want more.
- Guys, it's much more
simple than that, it's
like you put out as much
content as you can 'cause if it's quality
I mean, I wish Biggie
put out 11 more albums.
- No shit.
- It's just quality.
You either have one video in
you or you have a million.
Like, I think the reason I'll win is like,
I got a lot in my tank.
Because I'm good at social commentary
and analyzing social
behavior so I'm gonna have
a real good point of
view on augmented reality
and machine learning and cryptocurrency
and VR, like my shit will never change.
That's what I'm good at.
And if you can think 'em up in your dome
and make them viral forever, it will work.
- Yeah, I can, it's--
- And the truth is
there'll always be another
thing like a Viagra
that you can, and a twerking that you can
put together and make happen.
- That's what I was sayin'--
- It's unlimited.
- If I can--
- Once you understand the
psychology of what makes somebody tick,
it's actually unlimited
'cause then you can
use the chronut and
avocados or you can use
kale chips and pomegranates
or you can use,
like, or like if you
really expand your universe
or like, if you start getting into acting.
Like, the new girlfriend,
the new boyfriend,
your best buddy, on tour,
like you could fuckin--
- Yeah.
- Yeah, right.
- Sometimes it just keeps
me up, I'm just like man.
- The reverse, when she gets you.
- Right.
- Yeah.
It's just never ending.
- It's never ending.
If you can create, you can create.
- That's what I do all day,
like as we walk around.
- I get it, you watch.
- Yeah, oh yeah.
- 100%.
- Except for New York's
a little much for me.
(female laughing)
- New York's a little different.
- It's not that I, like
I tell people like,
it's just I'm so creative
that it's not that I'm like
PTSD I'm, it's so much for
my fuckin' head to take in
that I'm just like, I
need to like look, look.
Like I need to see fuckin'
everything that's goin' on.
I was at Times Square,
you should see that video.
I was just like this, I shit you not.
I just couldn't let it go.
- Brother, I live here, I get it.
Like it's, what happens
when you live in the vortex
you start like really
getting into a crazy place
because now it's like,
you know, it's almost like
a hard drug or anything
else, like, now I'm like
I gotta, now New York
feels really slow to me
and I'm just like, oh shit.
- Oh shit.
- Oh shit, I need to move
to like China or something.
- Yeah I've seen that, I was
just sayin' that earlier.
You think is crazy, my
buddy was live streamin'
in like Thailand and stuff.
- Somethin' rad.
- It's just I've
never seen it.
- I'm glad you guys
came through.
- I'm very happy.
- Yeah, thank you so much for everything.
- You're welcome.
- Give us a trip here too
as well.
- Yeah, it's fun.
Nice to spend some time
together too, away.
- Yeah it is, yeah.
- Like, likes lining up
all the, last night, man,
one of the fans goes,
yeah I used to work in
New York, I used to sit up
on the things with
binoculars so make sure you
close your shit.
- Literally.
(laughing)
- Listen to this one, I sit
down and I shit you not,
we're layin' down, dude
comes up in the thing across
from us with binoculars, creepin'.
- Oh my God.
- I was just squishin'
my bare white ass against the
window for like 10 minutes.
- Yeah.
- I swear I was just
like squishin' it there, like, he's gonna
see it eventually, you know.
- That's amazing.
- He probably thinks
it's a girl too.
(all laughing)
- You have a nice, cute little butt?
- Yeah, I guess so.
- I get it, I get it.
- He's probably thinkin' it's her but--
- I love it, guys thanks
for comin' through.
- Yeah thank you so much.
- Hit me any,
let me know if I can be of help.
- Okay.
- Of course Gary.
I just wanna grab a picture.
- You got it.
- I gotta get a picture with Gary.
Yeah, so this is what I
created, you like these cards?
- I do, it's nice.
- They're cool huh?
- Yeah.
- You know what sucks?
- What?
- Not only the amount
that I paid for 'em, my
fuckin' number changed.
(laughing)
- Fuck, really.
Why, it got out there and
you had to do somethin'?
- Yeah, it got a little too crazy.
- [Gary] Let's do a photo right here.
- Got it.
- Awesome.
- Thank you very much.
- You're welcome.
- You wanna take one with you?
- Sure.
- Can you take one
with me and her?
(upbeat music)